there's no doubt about it sometimes you
go back to an old game you used to love
start playing and realize that maybe
this wasn't as good as you thought it
was nostalgia is a powerful thing as it
happens however 2002's Resident Evil
remake holds up really well and Resident
Evil HD is here to prove it in fact this
HD remaster of a remake of a horror
classic does a great job of looking like
you remember it looking the reason
that's important is because the way you
remember it is almost always better than
the way it really looked new textures
new lighting and other nifty tweaks
don't make Resident Evil HD look like a
modern game exactly but it does look
like an older game through modern eyes
the gameplay tweaks are less substantial
the most significant addition is a
control scheme that lets you use the
analog stick to move in the direction
you're pushing otherwise Resident Evil
HD reveals the same mystery and requires
you to solve the same puzzles as the
2002 version you play as either Jill
Valentine or Chris Redfield who are
members of a special ops force called
stars you spend most of the time
exploring a mansion in which you become
trapped while investigating the
disappearances of other stars members
though it's soon clear that the fate you
should most worry about is your own
even purely within a modern context this
is an engrossing adventure that benefits
from tense exploration and clever
environmental puzzles people often talk
about the scary bits but Resident Evil's
finest asset is how it invigorates
exploration behind every door are
glimpses at a mansion's history hints of
experiments gone wrong and bizarre
contraptions that border on the occult
solving environmental puzzles means
gaining access to creepier areas and
learning more about the mansion setting
you're trapped within don't get me wrong
though the freights remain these kinds
of horror story jump scares are a matter
of routine and modern games and cinema
but you'll probably still jump when
those zombie dogs crash through the
glass the fear is enhanced by how
helpless you are when an enemy lands an
attack the dogs get all the attention
but it's the shark swimming around in
aquatic arena that always most terrified
me and man entering the aquatic circle
still gets me tense
you don't freely control the camera
during your endeavors every viewing
angle enhances the claustrophobia while
allowing Capcom to carefully place props
and lights for maximum effects some of
the most dangerous places are also given
the most limited screen space which in
turn intensifies that fight-or-flight
instinct Resident Evil was created with
a clear eye for shot composition which
makes exploration all the more tense
fixed camera can be a source of
frustration however it can be annoying
for instance to have the camera change
angle every few seconds because it means
having to quickly adjust to how that
changes character movement that's the
Resident Evil conundrum mechanics that
keep you nervous and cautious can also
bog things down there's that limited
inventory for instance it makes you
carefully consider what objects to keep
with you but it also leads to ridiculous
shuffling like going to your stash
putting in a puzzle object taking out an
increment going to the typewriter saving
your game going back to your stash
putting the ribbon back and
putting the thing back into your
inventory that kind of stuff doesn't
enhance the atmosphere so much as it
feels like it wastes time all the same
there's a beautiful simplicity to
Resident Evil HD it's a reminder that
the best mysteries don't need convoluted
stories to be enthralling later Resident
Evil games would add more viruses and
unnecessary subplots but the original
allows that menacing mansion to do most
of the talking in this series less is
more there's backstory to uncover but
the focus is on the here ends now it is
you the mansion and your imagination as
it happens that trio makes for a fine
adventure without the need for more
gameplay styles more outbreaks and more
guns
you